The following table
describes the relationship
between the number of
servings of spaghetti
bolognese-- I don't know
if I'm pronouncing that--
or bolognese, and the
number of tomatoes
needed to prepare them.
Test the ratios for
equivalents, and determine
whether the relationship
is proportional.
Well, you have a
proportional relationship
between the number of servings
and the number of tomatoes
is if the ratio of
the number of servings
to the number of tomatoes
is always the same.
Or if the ratio of
the number of tomatoes
to the number of servings
is always the same.
So let's just think about the
ratio of the number of tomatoes
to the number of servings.
So it's 10 to 6, which is
the same thing as 5 to 3.
So here the ratio is 5 to 3.
15 to 9, if you divide both
of these by 3, you get 5 to 3.
So it's the same ratio.
15 to 25, if you divide both
of these by 5, you get 5 to 3.
So based on this data,
it looks like the ratio
between the number of tomatoes
and the number of servings
is always constant.
So yes, this relationship
is proportional.